this video is sponsored by surf shark
VPN
every morning Emma gets up at exactly 5
a.m. she read once that the more you hit
the snooze button on your alarm the more
it can negatively affect her sleep and
make you groggy err throughout the day
so she trained herself to never hit the
snooze button again and promptly turns
the alarm off upon its first ring she
uses an alarm clock instead of her phone
keeping her phone in the other room so
to prevent her from using it when she
first wakes up as well as just before
going to bed because she also read that
smart phone usage during these times can
have a negative impact on mental health
and sleep quality upon waking up for no
more than a few moments Emma stretches
and relieves any tightened joints and
muscles from the previous night's sleep
which are almost always pretty minimal
due to the fact that she has perfected
her sleep through a sleep tracking app
and airtight sleep schedule and optimal
pillow and bedding products after
getting out of bed Emma brushes her
teeth counting - the American Dental
Association recommended 120 seconds
inside her head she can almost determine
120 seconds without even needing to
count but she does so anyway just to be
sure then she changes into her workout
clothes and regardless of the weather
goes out on her morning run reminding
herself when it's pouring that her body
never takes any days off so neither
should she following the run Emma does a
specific researched combination of
concentrated muscle exercises dependent
on the day of the week after exercising
she meditates for 30 minutes regulating
and observing her breath and mind
exactly how a variety of guided
meditations taught her which she has by
now combined into one super effective
single practice following meditation
Emma proceeds to shower using
all-natural organic soaps and shampoos
that she extensively researched for
quality control
Emma regularly stays up-to-date on
various data and research regarding
health habits products and practices
adapting her routine to every new
insight so long as she has adequately
analyzed the information and confirmed
that it is in fact accepted by the
majority portion of the particular field
it's coming from before promptly leaving
her home at 7:30 a.m.
she eats one of seven different
breakfast meals that she has curated
from leading dieticians she found online
each meal is similar enough to retain
equal nutritional balance while
different enough to ensure that she does
not get sick of any of them
after all Emma knows that variety is the
spice of life
Emma applies the same strategy to lunch
dinner and snacks throughout the day the
majority of which she meal preps every
Sunday every day on her way to work
Emma stops at a local homeless shelter
to help prepare cook and serve breakfast
for the local homeless residents she
frequently recommends new recipes and
general facility ideas to the head chef
as well as the executive director of the
shelter they thank her but have never
taken any of her recommendations emma
has made it clear to them that she is
aware of this but that she understands
that it is their facility and does not
mean to impose herself on their
expertise and is still very happy and
grateful for the opportunity to
volunteer the chef goes to great lengths
to avoid Emma when she's there following
her work at the shelter Emma continues
into downtown she parks her car in a
parking structure several blocks away
from the office where she works there
are parking areas surrounding the office
but they are small and don't fit
everyone and so even though she's almost
always early Emma never takes a spot so
that one less other person has to walk
while she walks to several blocks from
the structure to the office Emma waves
and says different iterations of joyful
greetings to every person she passes
within her sight line enunciated her
words with such volume and clarity to
ensure that no one misses a single
syllable she leaves and follows with a
big sincere smile that puts every
returned half clenched lips smile to
shame when she enters the office Emma
continues her joyful greetings believing
that a positive attitude and always
focusing on the good is the very best
way to live regardless of the day time
and her mood Emma goes around her
section of the office
sincerely inciting conversations and
comments were ever possible somehow
always having a quote of motivation at
the ready that seems to fit every
scenario some large percentage of her
co-workers hastily closed their office
doors if they have one as soon as they
hear her coming
once at her desk after all emails have
promptly and sufficiently been dealt
with and what proceeds to check her
calendar and daily planner she uses four
different scheduling apps that she
discovered through extensive research
regarding resources that help with
work habits and daily planning
throughout the day she stays
unbelievably focused and organized based
on a very specific weighting system of
prioritization that she learned and
developed from one of the many podcasts
articles and books she's referred to on
the subject her productivity level is
unfathomably high and she frequently but
appropriately keeps higher management
aware of where she's at in her work
checking that she is still on track in
the right direction providing and
fulfilling new ideas as often as she can
her bosses often tried to avoid her in
the hallways Emma makes a great salary
and is in a very high important position
at the company however without ever
letting anyone take advantage of her she
always works in a way that serves to
help those around her look better
rarely taking any credit she believes
that her work is enough of a reward in
it of itself in fact she even deferred
two of her most recent promotions to
other employees who she genuinely
believed were more deserving and don't
get enough recognition
whenever Emma talks with co-workers
family acquaintances or strangers she
listens with great attentiveness using a
variety of refined mirroring and
conversational techniques she learned
about to ensure that she properly
communicates her genuine sincerity and
intrigue towards other people if she
finds herself in a conversation in which
she thinks she can help someone she
always suggests and/or refers them to
some multifaceted in depth thoughtfully
specific combination of personal
practices and available resources on the
topic that might help and will always
clarifies that it's totally up to them
and that they should do whatever they
think is best for themselves affirming
that she does not mean to impose or
pressure them this is almost always
interpreted as passive aggressiveness or
internalized as subversive pressure
nearly every week
Emma invites her co-workers to outings
over the weekend primarily hikes bird
watchings volunteer activities museum
visits local community events Saturday
lunches in downtown neighborhood
cleanups and small little parties often
movie or game oriented at her house
Emma works very hard but knows that life
is short and is only as valuable as it
is fun which she is sure to always tell
her co-workers when they inform her that
they are unfortunately busy that weekend
out of every weekend emma has asked only
seven people have ever accepted five of
which never made it past their first
time during her free time
Emma often goes on retreats volunteer
trips into events and seminars that
either help communities and causes or
help her become a better and overall
more informed person Emma knows how to
play the clarinet
French horn piano and the Appalachian
dulcimer is proficient in five languages
sustains a small farm on a property
operates two additional ethical streams
of income is a member of her local
government and is a brown belt in
jujitsu and was health work ethic social
skills kindness success and weekly
routines are about as ideal as anyone
could possibly imagine
she is the culmination and totality of
what basically everyone strives to be
everything is synced up and perfected in
Emma's life except one thing no one
likes Emma for all intents and purposes
emma is without any friends her bright
constant earnest smile seems to
aggravate the blood of anyone near it
her unwavering kindness projected by her
perfected and impenetrable social skills
renders a frustration and exhaustion in
even the most patient and otherwise kind
social people
no one ever seems to really trust or
open up to Emma and she rarely if ever
experiences a real mutual connection or
conversation with anyone her daily
routines habits skills and demeanor make
those around her feel like constant
absolute failures some of her co-workers
and acquaintances find themselves
imagining horrible things happening to
Emma which terrifies them and makes them
want to avoid her altogether the
inescapable dread and disdain felt
towards Emma is confusing and illogical
it's a disdain that makes everyone feel
horrible about themselves for feeling it
towards her which makes everyone
involuntarily dislike Emma all the more
emma has eliminated all character flaws
and in doing so
perhaps one of the biggest flaws
imaginable without even realizing it
emma has discovered that even through
pure perfection the imperfection of life
still cannot be escaped but Emma always
reminds herself that adversity is just
an opportunity for improvement this
video was sponsored by sir shark VPN
surf shark is an easy-to-use VPN service
that keeps your IP address hidden
encrypts your data and scans for email
compromises protecting your identity
passwords photos and other personal
information from online threats one of
the many great features that sets surf
shark apart from other VPNs is that you
can use surf shark on as many devices as
you'd like at the same time with just
one subscription meaning all your
personal devices as well as your friends
and families by enabling you to change
your device's location surf shark allows
you to bypass various country
restrictions and censorships
letting you access any content from
anywhere no matter where you're
physically at in the world this can
allow you to access for example any of
the 15 varying libraries of Netflix that
are otherwise exclusive to residents of
their specific countries also as a
result of being able to easily change
your location you're able to potentially
uncover better prices for things like
airfare car rentals and other
accommodations that can sometimes be
price affected based on country
currently as low as just 177 a month
surf shark is a fantastic value and
provides several other great unique
features related to money savings
privacy protection and an overall
enhanced web browsing experience if
you're interested you can click the link
in the description or go to Surf shark
deals slash Powell and use the promo
code Powell for 85% off the regular
price plus three months for free of
course thank you so much for watching in
general and see you next video
you